[Música]
todos los días de su vida Usted se mueve
en sistema de poder que otras personas
crearon los detecta entiende el poder se
da cuenta de Porque es importante
con frecuencia nos incomoda hablar del
poder eso es especialmente cierto en la
vida cívica por vivir juntos en
comunidad en democracia se supone que el
poder debe residir en las personas
cualquier otra conversación sobre el
poder y quién realmente lo tiene parece
un tanto obscena tal vez incluso ruin
pero el poder no es mejor o peor que el
fuego o la física simplemente es
rige la forma en que funciona cualquier
gobierno Define Quién determinará las
reglas del juego Así que aprender Cómo
funciona el poder es clave para ser
eficaz para ser tomado en serio Y para
que no se aprovechen de uno
en esta lección veremos De dónde viene
el poder cómo se ejerce Y qué se puede
hacer para ser más poderoso en la vida
pública vamos a empezar con una
definición básica poder es la capacidad
de hacer que los demás hagan lo que
usted desee por supuesto esto aplica en
todos los ámbitos de la vida desde la
familia el lugar de trabajo hasta en
nuestras relaciones
nos centraremos en el ámbito Cívico
donde el poder significa conseguir que
una comunidad tome decisiones y que
actúe como usted desea hay seis fuentes
principales de poder Cívico primero
existe fuerza física y capacidad para la
violencia el control de la fuerza ya sea
policial o de una milicia es el poder en
su forma más primaria una segunda fuente
de poder es la riqueza el dinero
posibilita comprar resultados y comprar
casi cualquier otro tipo de poder
la tercera forma de poder es la acción
del Estado del gobierno es usar la ley I
burocracia para obligar a las personas a
que hagan o no ciertas cosas en una
democracia por ejemplo el pueblo en
teoría le da el poder al gobierno a
través de elecciones en una dictadura El
poder del Estado surge de La amenaza de
la fuerza y no del consentimiento de los
gobernados el cuarto tipo son las normas
sociales o lo que otros piensan que está
bien las normas no tienen la maquinaria
centralizada del gobierno operan de
manera más blanda pueden hacer que las
personas cambien el comportamiento e
incluso cambiar leyes
piense en la evolución de la igualdad en
el matrimonio
la quinta forma de poder son las ideas
una idea las libertades individuales o
la igualdad racial pueden generar un
enorme poder si se motiva a la gente
para que cambie sus acciones y
pensamiento y la sexta fuente de poder
es el número un montón de seres humanos
una masa resonante de personas crea
poder al expresar intereses colectivos y
afirmar su legitimidad
piense en la primavera árabe o el
ascenso del tipo la multitud cuenta
Estas son las seis principales fuentes
de poder
Así que ahora pensemos en Cómo opera el
poder hay tres leyes del poder que vale
la pena examinar
ley número 1 el poder Nunca es estático
está siempre aumentando o disminuyendo
en un ámbito Cívico Así que si no actúa
alguien lo hará por usted
ley número 2 el poder es como el agua
fluye como una corriente Por lo
cotidiano la política es aprovechar ese
flujo en la dirección que prefiera
formular políticas es un esfuerzo por
congelar y perpetuar un flujo de poder
en particular una política es poder
congelado
ley número 3 el poder se forma el poder
engendra más poder y lo mismo ocurre con
la falta de poder lo único que evita que
la ley número tres conduzca a una
situación donde solo una persona tenga
todo el poder depende de cómo apliquemos
las leyes uno y dos
qué reglas establecemos para que algunas
personas no acumulen poder y por lo
tanto no consagren sus privilegios en la
política
Ese es el punto de la democracia y se
puede ver el funcionamiento de cada una
de estas leyes en cualquier noticia
los trabajadores se organizan por
mejores salarios las petroleras
presionan por la aprobación de un
oleoducto parejas gay y lesbianas buscan
el derecho legal de casarse padres
urbanos exigen cheques escolares
usted puede apoyar estos esfuerzos o no
conseguir lo que quiera Depende de lo
hábil que sea con el poder
lo que nos lleva finalmente a lo que
puede hacer para ser más poderoso en la
vida pública aquí es útil pensar en
términos de alfabetización su desafío es
aprender a leer y escribir poder
leer poder significa prestar atención a
todos los textos de poder que pueda no
me refiero solo a libros me refiero a
ver a la sociedad como un conjunto de
textos no le gusta como son las cosas en
su campus o país analice quién tiene Qué
tipo de poder arraigado en Qué sistemas
entienda Por qué se desarrolló así quién
lo hizo así y quién quiere mantenerlo
así estudia las estrategias utilizadas
por otros en esas situaciones
ataque frontal o indirectas
coaliciones o autoridad carismática
lea para poder escribir para escribir
poder se requiere primero que crea que
tiene el derecho a escribir hacer un
autor del cambio lo tiene al igual que
con todo tipo de escritura usted aprende
a expresarse con una voz auténtica
organice sus ideas luego organice a
otras personas practique la creación de
consenso y el conflicto al igual que con
la escritura es todo cuestión de
práctica puede practicar todos los días
en su vecindario y más allá establezca
objetivos
observe los patrones observe que
funciona adapte repita esto es la
ciudadanía
[Música]
en esta breve lección hemos explorado De
dónde viene el poder Cívico cómo
funciona y qué puede hacer para
ejercerlo
una gran pregunta pendiente es el porqué
del poder quiere poder para beneficiar a
todo el mundo o solo a usted
son sus propósitos A favor o en contra
de lo social esta pregunta no es sobre
estrategias sino sobre carácter y eso es
para otra serie de lecciones Pero
recuerde esto poder más carácter es
igual a un gran ciudadano y usted tiene
el poder de ser uno
es posible que el abuso de poder no sea
una sorpresa pero es importante
comprender cómo sucede
eche un vistazo más de cerca a como
Hitler llegó al poder y al comercio de
esclavos por el Atlántico con estos
vídeos
[Música]